[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the trial for the men accused of
murdering ahmad arbury now did you ask
mr gregory michael how many shots there
were i did what did he say he said there
were two shots what defendant gregory
mcmichael told police just after
arbory's death and fallout from the
deadly astroworld concert festival
performer drake speaks for the first
time since the deadly crowd surge plus
hundreds of documents released in the
case of accused wife killer barry
morphew who the prosecution intends to
call as witnesses in the coming trial
and later expert testimony in the deadly
kenosha shootings this is the single
gunshot wound and it created lethal
injury involving the heart and lungs
hear from the prosecution's final
witness before it rests its case law on
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i am imran ansari in for brian buckmeyer
who is in georgia covering the death of
ahmad arbory trial here in new york i'm
alongside co-host terry austin
three men face life in prison if
convicted in the death of 25 year old
ahmad arbury in february of 2020 arbory
an unarmed black man was gunned down
while running near his brunswick georgia
home he died as a result of his injuries
defendants gregory and travis mcmichael
and william roddy brian face several
charges in connection to his death
including malice murder felony murder
and aggravated assault
father and son gregory and travis
mcmichael tailed arbory in their pickup
truck as he ran
travis mcmichael eventually shot aubry
and he's now claiming self-defense
brian followed along in his own pickup
truck and recorded the incident in a now
famous viral radio
after weeks of jury selection opening
statements began on friday at the glenn
county courthouse in georgia and that is
where our very own brian buckmeyer is
now live outside that georgia courthouse
brian police investigators took the
stand on tuesday what were the big
takeaways from their testimony
yes amron the focus on day three of the
trial were the statements by the
mcmichaels the day of ahmad arbore's
death and the lack of injuries on travis
mcmichael for trousering michael an
officer testified travis didn't ask for
medical attention and questioned whether
the mark on the back of his head was an
injury and for gregory mcmichael the
prosecution painted the picture through
his statements that he was operating on
assumptions not seeing aubrey in the
home the day of his death chasing him
merely because he was running from down
the street and screaming at him to stop
or he'd blow his head off defense pushed
back trying to show that the cries for
aubry to stop happened at the end of the
chase and not in the middle something
that went back and forth during redirect
and direct but what was really shocking
was what gregory michaels said he would
have done if he could on the stand
responding officer testified gregory
mcmichael called aubrey profanities in a
police interview as he stood just 20
feet from aubrey's body
what did he say then i saw him yeah in
fact if
if to be perfectly honest with you if i
could have got a shot at the guy i'd
have shot him myself and then does the
male speaker inquire about his son is
your son okay yes ma'am what's great
would michael say he's upset as hell
does he repeat that yes ma'am
and then the male speaker says i can
imagine
the male speaker then asks him a
question was the male speaker asking
about line 25 so the guy
the guy have a gun
and what does greg mcmichael say on the
top of page 28
no i don't know i mean i couldn't tell
if it's one on him or not
but he was he attacked my son
since sheffield objected to the
authentication of surveillance at the
construction site but the judge
overruled him do you think the judge
made the right call with that decision
actually not the judge has been great so
far but when it comes to authenticating
a video typically you need either an
individual in the video or someone who's
the custodian of the video equipment to
say that what is being shown in the
video is a true and accurate
representation of what it purports to be
an officer who merely downloads that
video can't really testify to that they
can testify to chain of custody but not
that what's being played in the video is
real and not slowed down or sped up as i
think jason sheffield correctly argued
right and it also sounds like things got
heated in that courtroom today brian to
the point that the judge excused himself
excuse the jury stepped off the bench
himself and had some choice words for
travis michael's defense team what
happened in the courtroom mike
so i think it actually build up for that
one aspect of the video coming in that
jason sheffield when cross-examining a
witness was trying to almost back door
away into getting a definition of
burglary that would have helped his case
the prosecution i think rightly in this
time objected to that and the judge
sustained it meaning it wasn't coming in
but jason sheffield gave at least a
physical expression towards the judge
not any kind of aggressive way but you
can just see he disregarded or had a
certain disdain sorry for that objection
and being sustained to the point that
the judge excused the jury and told him
in a way that almost is like your mother
is saying uh i'm disappointed in you
told jason sheffield that he was rude
and said that he the judge is actually
going to step off the bench so that
jason sheffield can think about what
he's doing
brian thank you for your great reporting
down there in georgia and we will be
keeping tabs on what is going on through
your great reporting and still ahead
here on law on crime daily we go inside
the kenosha courtroom where accused
murderer kyle rittenhouse is on trial
but first eight deaths and many injuries
after the astro world music festival in
houston our very own anjanet levy is
live with the latest comments from the
headliners of that event
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charge will now stand
trial for live galvado gabo coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
[Music]
welcome back and the family of a
nine-year-old boy who's fighting for his
life after the astroworld concert
tragedy files a lawsuit law on crime's
angelette levy is here with what the
suit claims and more about the child
angeannette
yeah imran his name is ezra blount he
was actually at astroworld with his
father when he was injured and right now
he is on life support at a texas
hospital
ezra blount's family has set up a
gofundme account to raise money for his
medical expenses a lawsuit filed by
attorneys for ezra's family claims
negligence in a number of areas
including crowd control failure to
provide medical attention training and
more travis scott live nation and
several others are named in the suit in
a statement attorney ben crump wrote
this young child and his family will
face life-altering trauma from this day
forward a reality that nobody expects
when they buy concert tickets this
little boy is currently fighting for his
life and his parents will never know the
same child they entered astroworld with
for the first time we are hearing from
rapper drake he posted on instagram i've
spent the past few days trying to wrap
my head around this devastating tragedy
i hate resorting to this platform to
express an emotion as delicate as grief
but this is where i find myself my heart
is broken for the families and friends
of those who lost their lives and for
anyone who is suffering eight people
were killed friday night as the crowd
pushed toward the stage during travis
scott's performance a memorial has taken
shape outside of nrg park where a
criminal investigation is underway
and houston's fire chief actually told
the today show that travis scott and
others should have stopped the concert
when they realized what was happening
the music still played on for a time
while this whole event was unfolding
imran
yeah it's a real tragedy and let's bring
back my co-host terry austin and also
joining with us now is criminal defense
attorney adam konta adam thanks for
being here i'm going to start with you
we have now heard from rapper drake on
social media expressing his condolences
do you think that drake or any of the
any of the other performers at the
concert could face some liability here
well it depends what you mean i i don't
see any criminal liability yet uh
although this is obviously an
unspeakable tragedy i think there are
certainly going to be some civil
remedies and some civil avenues that
they all explore and we're starting to
see what i'm sure will be an avalanche
of lawsuits but as of yet i don't see
any criminal liability
and terry do you think that this
incident could result in some
legislation
to protect concert goers at concerts
going forward
it actually could enron i mean right now
we know that under you know common tort
law you can sue for negligence and we
are seeing that already multiple suits
have been made against the organizers
against the performers
but we know for a fact that there are
some statutes in texas which protect
concert goers and the property owner
right now has a duty under the law in
texas to protect the patrons and make
sure they hire security that is licensed
to protect those patrons but i do
anticipate that at some point in time we
could see additional legislation
additional standards to make sure that
something like this never happens again
right and antoinette we know that there
are civil lawsuits have that have been
filed already
what is the status of the criminal
investigation
well imran we know that the houston
police department has opened this
criminal investigation but now the fbi
is also a part of it and so
live nation they were the promoter
putting on this show they actually
stopped removing equipment and other
items from nrg park
so that the investigators could still
walk through get a proper lay of the
land as all of this was unfolding so
this is very much an active criminal
investigation whether or not anyone will
ultimately face criminal charges we'll
just have to wait and see
it's a real tragedy and we'll be
watching as the legal developments
unfold and coming up here on law and
crime daily state prosecutors rest their
case in the murder trial of accused
kenosha shooter kyle rittenhouse plus
hundreds of pages of inside information
now released in the case of accused
white killer barry morphew what court
documents reveal about morpheus arrest
and investigation
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to law on crime daily and
nearly 500 pages of court documents and
investigative notes have been released
in the case of accused murderer barry
morphew on monday a colorado judge
released the previously private
documents detailing several key
takeaways the 454 pages of motions
filings and court orders show more few
refused to take a polygraph exam
following his arrest the documents also
include a list of more than 500
potential witnesses for the prosecution
including morphy's two adult daughters
co-workers fbi agents and colorado
investigators all this comes as the
defense claims the prosecution withheld
some key evidence from the case
including a forensic image of more few
cell phone and recordings from a spy pen
morphew is accused of killing his wife
suzanne murphy who went missing on
mother's day in 2020 though a body has
never been found morphew faces a first
degree murder charge right now a trial
is scheduled for may of 2022
let's bring in
our great guest adam konta and my
co-host terry austin adam um adam i'm
gonna start with you we are learning
that barry morpheu declined to take a
lie detector test could that work
against him in any way
uh you know only if he has a bad defense
attorney lie detector tests are it's a
misnomer to even call it a lie detector
test what they are really are sort of
body response tests and there is no
basis in in the scientific community
that they work there's nothing in the
scientific community that says this is
an accurate method of testing someone's
veracity
and it should never be used it should
never ever ever ever be used i would
never allow a client of mine to use one
and he did the right thing this is
totally apart from if he did or did not
commit uh the heinous act of murder
against his wife a lie detector text is
bogus science that only exists in the
popular cultural world because of movies
and television it's one of those things
that you should be able to dismiss as a
defense attorney very easily and so i i
hope that it would not be used against
him and and in fact that he would that
it's more that the science of
the pseudoscience of lie detector test
would be put on
put on trial in that moment versus his
decision right and terry the defense is
claiming that the prosecution has not
revealed all of the evidence does the
prosecution have an obligation to
disclose to the defense their evidence
yeah absolutely there's no question
about it they have a continuing
obligation to disclose evidence
particularly if it's exculpatory
evidence meaning evidence that would
show the innocence of the defendant so
that has to be revealed or else they
face a possible brady violation so they
also have to just make sure they give
all of their witnesses and that they
give all of their expert witnesses and
the reports as far as that's concerned
so i think at this point we're seeing
all these pages talking about what the
evidence might be and it makes sense for
that to be disclosed at this point prior
to when we know trial is going to be
imminent in the next few months terry
and adam great analysis and now on to
news from our chief investigative
correspondent brian ross who this week
investigates the case of environmental
lawyer stephen donziger who sued
oil company chevron on behalf of
thousands of indigenous people in
ecuador brian ross is here to tell us
more about this week's episode brian
thanks coming up this week on brian ross
investigates the latest on the american
lawyer steve donziger who went to the
amazon to help the people there fight
against a giant american oil company and
now finds himself behind bars in the
united states his spirits are good
uh you know steve is remarkably
resilient he wouldn't have been able to
fight you know chevron and and its
corporatist tools for as long as he had
uh without being resilient a jail is
obviously a new experience for him but
he's not in camp fed here
uh he's in a low security institution
which you know mostly means the
other prisoners are are all there for
non-violent offenses but some of them
are serving
uh very long sentences uh he's in
dormitory style housing there's 59
people crammed together in one room
people doing their laundry and hanging
laundry on the pipes and and stephen
said it actually
looked like some of the refugee camps
that he visited and now he's a a part of
that's coming up this week on brian ross
investigates on the law and crime trial
network back to you
thank you brian and you can watch brian
ross investigates on the law and crime
trial network tuesdays and thursdays at
5 30 and 10 30 eastern time
and when we come back the state rests
this case in what the judge calls the
most divisive case in the country we
take you inside the kenosha courtroom
where the medical examiner testifies in
the state of wisconsin versus kyle
rittenhouse
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
prosecution rests this case in trial of
accused kenosha shooter kyle rittenhouse
18 year old rittenhouse faces multiple
charges including first degree murder
reckless murder and attempted murder
following the august 2020 shootings in
kenosha wisconsin
prosecutors say rittenhouse shot and
killed joseph rosenbaum and anthony
huber and injured gage gross croits
rittenhouse's team argues the defendant
was acting in self-defense
on tuesday the state called its final
witness medical examiner dr doug kelly
who performed the autopsy on both huber
and rosenbaum he testified that huber's
autopsy was performed first the morning
after the shooting
were you able to determine the cause of
death to mr huber yes and what was that
cause of death
mr huber died from a gunshot wound to
the chest it uh basically travels
through his chest and creates trauma to
both of the lungs and and specifically
to the heart there's a lot of damage to
the heart
dr kelly testified he performed the
autopsy on joseph rosenbaum the
following day he detailed rosenbaum's
cause of death while on the stand
we've talked about how the other
injuries were not ones that would
immediately cause a mortal wound
what impact do you believe that this
gunshot would have had on mr rosenbaum
this gunshot wound is a lethal injury
this
gunshot wound is the
one that would cause
death as a result of the injuries to the
lungs and the liver with the hemorrhage
and the injury to the organs themselves
and while the prosecution used dr
kelly's testimony to show joseph
rosenbaum fell into rittenhouse after
being shot
the defense on the other hand argued
rosenbaum was pursuing written house at
the time of the shooting
you would agree that this shooting of mr
rosenbaum which is captured partially on
video is a dynamic situation correct
correct and
if the furthest he was away
with the stipeling that you see in the
wounds was four feet and closing that
goes very quickly correct if someone's
running at you
yes okay
and
four feet
quick if
that's about correct and if i had my
hands out i'm even closer correct yes if
i'm lunging and going for your gun which
is an extension away from your body
closer still yes
okay so terry and adam let's break this
down adam gonna start with you
a big deal has been made about whether
rosenbaum fell forward or whether he was
lunging forward do you think that it
makes a difference here
i think it makes a difference um you
know to get to the bar of intentional or
reckless homicide they really have to
show obviously that he was acting in
self-defense and that rosenbaum was
really really trying to attack him and
use uh everything in his power to not
only disarm uh kyle rittenhouse but to
harm him and you know i gotta say from
all the testimony that i've heard so far
and seen i think the prosecution is
gonna have a really tough time getting a
homicide charge out of this this sounds
like someone who is mentally unstable
who may have had a chain and whether it
was lunging or
falling it matters semantically but
if written house thought he was lunging
and they can show that that was his
mindset then i think the defense has
done all they need to do
yeah i agree terry the coroner testified
that the decedents suffered massive
injuries why do you think rittenhouse
brought an ar-15 rifle to the scene
you know that's an excellent question
imran listen he said he was there to
provide medical assistance and to
protect if you're there to provide
medical assistance you should be
bringing medical equipment why not bring
a defibrillator he brings instead an
ar-15 and if you are shot with an ar-15
rifle you are likely to be killed you
heard the coordinator there talking
about the bullet wounds that these
individuals sustained and so there's no
question that he went there with the
intention if he had any problems to
shoot to kill so that's a problem
terry and adam great analysis thank you
for joining us thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily where we
will see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you